[Musica]
so stare so stare so fermarmi e so
restare Ma siamo sicuri di essere ancora
in grado di farlo perché questa cosa
l'abbiamo disimpara ne abbiamo imparate
tantissime Ma questa ce la siamo
dimenticata ed è un perolo È un rischio
è un rischio perché in un momento in cui
occupiamo uno spazio fisico sempre più
ristretto ma uno spazio digitale più
ampio in cui siamo iperconnessi in cui
siamo diffusi e in cui siamo
dematerializzati come facciamo a non
perdere la nostra identità e in un
momento in cui tutto quello che ci
circonda fra 6 mesi fra un anno sarà
vecchio e lo butteremo e non l'
aggiusteremo e ne compreremo un upgrade
più giovane e più performante Come
facciamo a non buttare le persone e in
un momento in cui abbiamo risposte
immediate a tutto ai nostri bisogni Come
facciamo a non considerare le nostre
relazioni importanti della nostra vita
semplicemente come delle risposte ai
nostri
bisogni Come facciamo Non lo so ma
adesso l'ho scoperto l'ho scoperto
perché ho scritto tantissime storie e le
decine e le decine di storie mi hanno
insegnato qualche cosa di molto
importante quando io avevo i miei
bambini piccoli ehm andavamo in giro
molto insieme ci trovavamo non so al
alla coda al supermercato piuttosto che
al ristorante e i miei figli mi dicevano
mamma ti stai Ti stai fissando mamma non
fissarli perché io sono sempre stata
innamorata delle storie delle persone
delle persone vere e quindi è vero li
fissavo non per curiosità ma per
interesse perché mi piaceva pensare che
che relazione ci fosse fra di loro che
cosa si potesse imparare da quella
storia e loro mamma mamma non ti
incantare ti sta incantando e io mi
incantavo e così incanto dopo incanto ne
ho fatta la mia professione perché ho
scoperto che il patrimonio narrativo
delle storie ha un potere magico
trasforma le esperienze vissute da
qualcuno in esperienza vivente per tutti
ed esperienze singolari In esperienze
plurali per tutti e così dopo averne
raccontate davvero tante di persone e
relazioni che erano riuscite comunque ad
avere cura di sé a navigare le tempeste
e a non trasformare quella relazione in
un'arma ma a farne un'impresa epica mi
sono chiesta come tutte queste storie
fossero collegate era il momento per me
della restituzione volevo capire questi
protagonisti così diversi per età per
cultura per potere sociale che cosa
hanno in comune Ebbene tutti erano
capaci di esercitare il potere del
pensiero
riconoscente Che cos'è il il pensiero
riconoscente È il pensiero che ci
permette tutti i giorni prima di tutto
di cominciare a conoscere di nuovo le
persone che amiamo le persone con cui
siamo in relazione perché non sono mai
come erano il giorno prima ci permette
di amarli per quello che sono e non per
quello che Noi vorremo che fossero e ci
permette di essere grati e quindi oggi
facciamo questa strada all'interno di
questa casa immaginaria degli affetti e
apriremo queste porte una dopo l'altra
come le matriosche e arriveremo alla
porta d'ingresso o d'uscita e vedremo
che cosa succede queste porte sono sei
che è un numero ma è anche un verbo tu
sei e io ti vedo e questo è il pensiero
riconoscente Prima Porta partiamo dalle
basi dalla parola perché le parole
definiscono i valori che nominano e
quindi relazione deriva dal latino
referre Che significa portare a portare
verso quindi relazione è un'azione da me
a te Ma quindi anche l'amore è una
relazione da me a te e quindi amare
l'amore è amare non a essere amati E
questa Wow non è una frase utopica è una
frase logica perché noi siamo al governo
solo delle nostre azioni e naturalmente
dovremmo amare nella reciprocità perché
L'amore non corrisposto è un'
autocombustione ma siamo capaci di avere
il volante solo di ciò che facciamo noi
e quindi se invece noi amo ameremo
l'altro per quello che ci dà per quanto
soddisfa i nostri bisogni potranno
succedere due cose la prima che creeremo
una dipendenza molto forte e attenzione
perché alla cabina del comando c'è
sempre più più chi dà che chi riceve
perché chi dà agisce e potrebbe smettere
Chi riceve invece reagisce ama solo in
base a quanto riceve ma soprattutto se
amiamo l'altro per quello che
riceviamo cercheremo comunque di amare
solo la sua prestazione non ameremo lui
E allora cosa accadrà che quando quella
prestazione scricchiola e negli anni
scricchiola Perché le persone si
stancano si ammalano e si distraggono
Noi dovremmo prendere il nostro
modellino
ideale pieno di flag e appiccicarli
addosso a qualcun altro e li reggerà un
po' Ma poi cadrà come una figurina di
carta e invece noi dobbiamo imparare ad
amare le persone per quello che sono
quando non sono impegnate ad essere
innamorate di noi e solo così ameremo la
loro forza il loro coraggio i loro
Talenti e anche i loro difetti e le loro
imperfezioni e solo così saremo pronti
per aprire la seconda
porta conversare dobbiamo imparare a
conversare e guardate che ancora questa
parola è una parola bellissima versare
con io con te verso qualcosa e lo
condividiamo Ma io continuo a essere io
e tu continui a essere tu ed è per
questo che noi possiamo guardarci e
riconoscerci e io ti posso ascoltare
davvero senza pensare a subito una
risposta come di solito facciamo con i
nostri figli senza giudicarti subito mi
faccio portare nel tuo mondo e ti guardo
e lì sì che ti posso chiedere aiuto
perché l'amore non deve salvarci Ma le
persone che noi amiamo se le stimiamo e
ci fidiamo possiamo affidarci e farci
portare da loro in un mondo che ancora
non abbiamo visto in un mondo
straordinario dove c'è una soluzione che
prima non vedevamo perché se l'amore ci
lascia nella nostra zona comfort è un
amore che non cresce ed è un amore che
prima o poi
morirà Attenzione però come noi possiamo
gioire perché la persona che amiamo
gioisce perché ha vinto perché ha
realizzato un sogno la nostra deve
essere una gioia nostra autentica Avete
presente quando ci dicono Sono felice
per te ma se io amo qualcuno e lui è
felice lo vivo di una felicità mia
qualcuno di voi quando vince la squadra
del cuore è felice per loro si Siamo
felici per noi e questo però accade
anche nel dolore attenzione all'empatia
perché se io ti amo e soffro il dolore
che soffri tu e sono ingaggiato nelle
tue ferite chi ci darà una mano io devo
soffrire perché vedo tu che stai male ma
io ho ancora la mia indipendenza sono
altro da te ho il mio mondo che può
aiutarti a mettere pace nella tua guerra
a mettere ordine nel tuo disordine il
mio mondo resta mio i miei panni restano
miei i tuoi non li posso indossare e
questa è una cosa sana buona e giusta
perché solo così possiamo aiutarci
qualcuno di voi si farebbe mai operare
da un chirurgo che nell'atto chirurgico
è empatico non credo E quindi dobbiamo
portare all'altro il nostro mondo nuovo
e capace e allora questo mondo siamo
alla terza porta è fondamentale Avere
altro oltre l'amore è è importantissimo
per difenderlo perché se io vivo solo
nei tuoi occhi nel momento in cui tu ti
distrai ti addormenti ti annoi o guardi
altrove io muoio e ti do una
responsabilità troppo alta se io vivo
solo per te se io vivo per attenderti
cosa ti chiedo in cambio una moneta
troppo alta ti ingaggio in una gabbia
che è quella di rendermi felice io devo
avere felicità altrove mondi miei mondi
miei in cui mi sento me stessa mi sento
brava capace mi sento felice e prendo
energia e sarà questa energia che
portiamo dentro alla relazione perché
una relazione che vede sullo sfondo
tutto offuscato che vede solo se stessa
è un'energia Senza luce senza parole
senza idee ed è una relazione che morirà
di soffocamento è una relazione dove ci
sono due
cannibali ed è con questo che ci
portiamo alla quarta porta se io ho un
altro mondo che cosa vuol dire vuol dire
che le relazioni appartengono al mondo
del possibile non appartengono al mondo
del certo al mondo del certo del per
sempre dell'Eterno appartengono solo le
cose morte o le cose che non sono più
vive e noi dobbiamo considerare le
nostre relazioni invece come qualcosa di
vivo sempre di sempre attuale di sempre
oggi crederci come un atto di Fede
perché nessun credente potrà mai dire di
avere la certezza che Dio esiste se lo
sapessimo non ci sarebbe bisogno di
crederci sarebbe scienza e invece
crederci È quello che ci chiama
all'appello tutti i giorni Questo
significa che allora se non sarà per
sempre cadiamo nella disillusione non
promettiamo più no dobbiamo promettere
avere questo coraggio questa audacia
perché la promessa crea un confine che
se noi scavalcherà comunque la strada
per tornare a casa la promessa crea una
protezione dentro la quale le cose
valgono Perché dove non c'è confine dove
Vale tutto non vale niente E allora che
cosa ci dice l'amore Abbi fede Credici
mettici le gambe tutti i giorni come in
questa meravigliosa opera di Alessia
Ottaviani quest'opera si chiama semina e
raccogli semina e raccogli due verbi di
azione quotidiana e Allora noi due anche
se non Siamo fusi perché non dobbiamo
esserlo però noi siamo in equilibrio
tutti i giorni io sento la tua energia e
io sento la tua presenza e io e te
sappiamo sostare e io e te sappiamo fare
di un oggetto inanimato un'opera d'arte
e quindi tutto ok tutti vissero felici e
contenti Eh no qua dobbiamo metterci un
punto di domanda perché purtroppo
siccome lo sapevamo che poteva non
essere per sempre succede che non sia
per sempre E succede che accada il
tradimento e l'abbandono e a quel punto
e a quel punto
Dipende se ci avremmo creduto senza
averne certezza se ci avremmo creduto
con delle gambe forti se ci avremmo
creduto ma avevamo un mondo di
salvataggio nostro saremo feriti Sì
saremo tristi saremo nel lutto avremo
una bomba atomica nel cuore Sì ma saremo
disperati saremo ciechi no disperati
vuol dire senza speranza no se noi ci
avremmo creduto senza averne certezza
avremo la capacità di Sostare in quel
dolore perché non possiamo cancellarlo
ma avremo anche la capacità di attendere
che è un'altra parola spettacolare
perché attendere vuol dire sto lì ma
guardo verso tendo verso il
futuro
però però per tendere verso il futuro e
alzarci da quella solitudine abbiamo
bisogno di fare di sbrigare questa
piccola pratica che si chiama perdono e
il pensiero riconoscente per una volta
non è d'accordo con la parola Perché
perdono significa perdono dimenticando
senza chiedere nulla in cambio E allora
cosa ci viene da pensare che forse
questo è un potere solo Divino m m mica
tanto perché la più bella narrazione di
perdono che sia mai stata scritta è nel
Vangelo è proprio nel Vangelo perché il
Vangelo che ci si creda o no è un
grandissimo libero ispirazionale e nel
Vangelo c'è un episodio in cui Gesù
incontra Pietro è già successo tutto
Gesù è risorto è stato Crocifisso ha
fatto l'ultima cena e ha detto a Pietro
Pietro prima che canti Il gallo tu mi
tradirai tre volte e Pietro si straccia
le vesti Ma no Gesù Io ti amo io darò la
vita per te attenzione a chi dice darò
la vita per te E poi cosa succede a un
certo punto che Gesù viene catturato e
stanno un po' cercando i complici Quindi
vanno da Pietro e gli dicono Pietro
Allora tu è Gesù best friends No è lui
entra nel panico si dimentica tutto si
dimentica l'amore le preghiere il
percorso fatto insieme si dimentica le
promesse entra nel panico e lo nega E
allora Che cosa succede quando Gesù
rincontra Pietro potevano accadere molte
cose Pietro va verso Gesù e lui se l'era
un po' messa via No aveva detto Vabbè
dai ricomincio a fare il pescatore non
c'è problema perché poi quando si
tradisce tradiamo Prima di tutto noi
stessi abbiamo i sensi di colpa e ce la
mettiamo via e la cancelliamo e invece
Gesù che cosa ha fatto poteva dirgli
Vabbè dai io sono Gesù sono capace ti
perdono tranquillo Oppure poteva dirgli
Ecco Te l'avevo detto Ti rendi conto ti
avevo detto Pietro su questa Pietra
fonderò la mia chiesa lo sapevo me
l'aspettavo Dammi tutte le tue password
dei tuoi device nessuno niente di questo
sapete cosa ha fatto Gesù ha detto
Pietro Guardami mi vuoi bene mi vuoi
bene mi vuoi bene tre volte e quindi
questo che cosa vuol dire vuol dire che
noi per perdonare non dobbiamo
dimenticare dobbiamo entrare con la
persona che ci ha ferito in questo
dolore e ricordarglielo e dirgli Tu mi
hai hai fatto malissimo c'è una ferita
così aperta Però a quel punto è lì che
possiamo perdonare cercando di scindere
la persona da quello che ci ha fatto e
quindi per passare da Gesù a vascorossi
grande filosofo
contemporaneo non sono gli uomini a
tradire ma i loro guai e vascolo canta
in una canzone che si intitola Credici
davvero e soprattutto Gesù che cosa ha
fatto gli ha chiesto mi vuoi bene che
vuol dire Cosè restato di tutto il
nostro amore niente è
impossibile lì scatta il perdono nel
vedere che cosa è rimasto e questo non
significa perdonare non significa
continuare a stare insieme però
significa liberare noi stessi e l'altro
dal rancore perché il dolore di un lutto
di un tradimento se è un dolore risolto
è sano e guarirà quando invece abbiamo
un
debito di dolore quando abbiamo un
debito emozionale allora quel dolore
sarà un'agonia tutta la vita e non
saremo mai liberi e ci lascerà
lì sesta porta ultima porta la porta
delle porte la porta d'Oro quella che
divide la nostra casa l'amore del dentro
con l'amore del fuori e il pensiero
riconoscente ci chiede di tenere queste
due geografie ben distinte perché fuori
noi saremo tanto più amati quanto saremo
Capaci coraggiosi ricchi famosi
performanti perché quello è un amore
legato al merito in casa l'amore
Dovrebbe essere
gratis quante volte soprattutto coi
nostri ragazzi coi nostri figli che
stanno male quante volte quando arrivano
a casa la prima cosa che chiediamo è
come Come'è andata Guardate che Comè
andata vuol dire a me interessa In che
classifica sei nel mondo e loro vivono
tutti i giorni là fuori una guerra al
perfezionismo una guerra al rialzo
Invece noi dobbiamo cambiare la parola
cominciamo a chiedere alle persone che
amiamo Prima di tutto come stai Questo
Che cosa significa che non ci sono
regole che non ci sono doveri
Assolutamente no ma che vengono dopo
vuol dire che non devono esserci
conflitti Certo coi nostri figli i
conflitti sono sani perché non c'è
crescita senza crisi e non c'è crisi
senza conflitto le relazioni crescono di
cambiamento in cambiamento ma devono
avere chiaro che la relazione fra noi e
loro che il nostro amore per loro non
viene intaccato da quello che sbagliano
dalle regole che trasgrediscono E
soprattutto noi con questo Come stai
Dobbiamo dire a loro che quello che c'è
fuori è un mondo performante ma in casa
La casa è il luogo dove le cose
dovrebbero riposare e dove le cose
dovrebbero farci sentire al sicuro
abbracciati accolti e se noi questo
messaggio ai nostri figli che li amiamo
per quello che sono e non per quello che
fanno e non li identifichiamo con le
loro prestazioni se noi non lo passiamo
Guardate che loro non smetteranno di
amare noi smetteranno di amare se stessi
ed è quello che sta succedendo le St le
statistiche lo dicono I ragazzi stanno
male non è solo la nostra responsabilità
Ma almeno noi amiamoli chiedendo loro
come stai perché saranno Capaci con
tutte le porte aperte di venire a dirci
male mamma non sono quello che tu pensi
che io sia non solo quello che tu
vorresti che fossi non sono la
proiezione dei tuoi desideri non sono
qui per farti sentire brava o non sono
per qui per essere adeguato io sono
quello che voglio diventare che devo
diventare e questo mondo mi sta facendo
male E
allora
come stai vuol dire Ti voglio
bene come stai vuol dire voglio il tuo
bene e sono grata del fatto che tu sia
qui perché anche la gratitudine è
un'azione da me a te
grazie
di